foreign
ocean has been for several months
complaining about the top graph of the
Russian military he has been saying that
uh they are causing the deaths of
thousands of Russian soldiers he has
criticized their strategy and techniques
he has been extremely careful not to
name directly Vladimir Putin but of
course the underlying message here is a
criticism of the president he has
basically questioned why the war
actually took place
[Music]
criticism of what the Kremlin calls its
special military operation and criticism
of the government and the president
himself is extremely rare pregosian had
this latitude to do this and mainly
because he was seen before these current
events as a really strong Ally of
Vladimir Putin
is
at this particular juncture one wouldn't
probably say that this is going to crush
Vladimir Putin that may still take some
time if that happens at all what the
Kremlin will try and do is contain
figures and prevent him from marching on
Moscow it's hundreds of miles from
Moscow and to get from rustov to Moscow
they would have to to navigate quite a
treacherous path because they're not
going to be allowed to just walks into
the Russian capital of course there is
going to be this sense of instability
and it's it's Russians against Russians
and this is going to be terrifying and
demoralizing for a lot of the Russian
population